here with reaction attorney for former
president donald trump alina haba along
with the former chairman of the house
intel committee devin nunes selena let's
start with and the wall street journal
pointed this out yesterday our own greg
jarrett pointed it out on air last night
and that is the the federal records act
actually gives authority to a former
president to have custody and control of
presidential papers now when you
accompany that with the timeline that we
know of that is february we know that
the national archives and record
administration was praising the trump
team for their cooperation and in june
the fbi and doj had access to everything
they wanted to see and they they're the
ones that said would you mind padlocking
this room and they did it when you put
all of that together and the president's
ability to declassify
where did they get the president on any
legal issue here
i don't think that they did get him on
any legal issue here and that was the
headline on the wall street journal
yesterday which was
dead on accurate um you have to have a
legal basis this is not theatrics this
is our country this is the constitution
so what we saw was
the trail as in with the mueller report
that you just discussed that is that
they're hiding doj memos they they like
to conceal them they like to redact them
and then when push comes to shove they
pretend that they're doing us a favor
when it's not a favor it's his
constitutional right to say that these
documents are declassified he has that
right he doesn't need to ask anybody
else so what is the basis he was
cooperating
yeah devin we've been through this with
the russia collusion hoax and it was
three long years of unpeeling every
layer of every onion that we have here
what's fascinating too
is this is the exact same fbi office
that was involved in that russia
collusion
falsehood that they perpetrated on the
american people the same exact people
now why would we believe them now why
would we trust them now and why weren't
any of those people held accountable
well look we shouldn't and strzok and
his team have been replaced by a new
cabal so i don't know if they were
trained by strzok but one of the things
that i've been saying that republicans
are going to have to get a hold of and
ultimately i think president trump and
his legal team are going to have to get
a hold of if it is indeed true
that these agents worked for moeller and
they went on to
to the new york sdny
uh cases they went on to january 6th
they went on to the raid at mar-a-lago
these people are no better than strzok
and page and hopefully it's true that
some fbi agents are now coming forward
because that's one thing we didn't have
back in the day of the russia hoax at
the height of it but i would also say
this the focus on mueller should be
focused on this
mueller and his team
should be under investigation i called
for it at the time and i still call for
it today i don't know if durham will
ever get to them but perhaps maybe some
of these fbi agents are involved in this
latest raid on mar-a-lago devin good to
see you and congrats on truth and its
success truth social and alina thank you
for being with us hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else